hi guys I'm Greg and I'm Renee area
renee area we like an afterbuzz TV or an
Amber placer channel is a friend of the
Greg the Greg wants you to go check out
Renee on Instagram Twitter and YouTube
immediately as a matter of fact don't
watch this video you go over there
watch it I already got the click on here
you know even though YouTube page based
off you know audience watch time I don't
care about invisible go go go
followership stop this video you call
yourself the Greg the Greg yeah the
Greggy the Greg inator the Greg a Tron
oh you have a lot of nicknames for you
like a wash I know I just made all this
before
hey Renee my um you you've seen an
animated movie or two right yeah I'm
assuming you have to have make a mess
surprise I have seen this a couple in my
day all right well there's this new one
called fur demand which I hear is based
on the classic children's tale that I
know nothing about me neither but a few
people send in a request for this first
one b1g red is o14 Wow why is your name
so complicated you'll never get laid
think again late she has a dating blog
that is actually really funny that I
haven't promoted in any other video
oh yeah don't follow it with such
Mulligan it's called sexting and the
city.com vaccine in this seriously I
read a lot of it it was really really
funny and really entertaining and my
results with women have gone way lower
so I'm telling you guys you gotta go
check it out
right from the mole of your name people
think the guys you all figured out based
on how you look how you talk where
you're from but it's not that simple II
when it comes to me I'm a little bit
more complainant look at me you think me
you think scary
hey well this is not a china shop oh no
baby step baby step for the old lady
take me back see win
Oh romance
[Music]
whoa aah fighting you don't need to be a
fighting bull you just have to look like
a fire you see the Pharaoh over there
set it to pieces that's good what else
you gonna hit it with
ready
[Music]
sorry I almost kill you I'm always moist
for a good pun
now that was hilarious I love like the
little quick animation bit like when the
woman's watering the flowers and she was
a love staney little animated bits like
that what do you think Renee I had no
idea this was about a bowl and I was
very pleasantly surprised absolutely I
was automatically into it also they play
some Ed Sheeran in the background into
it so I'm gonna watch this movie
I think it looks great actually looks
like really fun I feel like I'm gonna
cry there's something in it it's like
I'm I cried this because of being a bowl
and then you know living amongst people
and yours automatically just viewed it
like this scared I know what it's like
you know people see me and they're like
oh what's this mess this huge mess just
walking through the streets here she
didn't want to be here today she would
like and we Skype meet her in not a
problem I'm sorry it's just I don't
think you're superficial or eight days
it's the most requested thing that
people don't actually sit next to me
so I know what it's like to be a bowl
you know I like just watching this
tracer I know so sorry yeah you
sympathize with him she's just trying to
do the right thing all the time you
could tell he's that guy who's like I'm
just trying to be kind to people to try
to be nice and everyone's like scared or
doesn't want me around what was he doing
in that and that I'm not trying to shop
over that that's what I didn't
understand why did he end up there he's
like oh boy I've never done like loops
um I'm around all's good China like
that's never happened to me and why was
why was the source set up that way hey
what is a human washing wrong this was
not a way to organize the words make it
this is this is not follow the rules of
reality the way we would like it to is
what we're trying to tell you
they're gonna be a talking bowl but you
need a work your work yeah I mean it's
always so far my imagination yes stretch
say a bird that a lady she could I would
like a window with other glass and like
a she's okay
a toaster shows doesn't have them over
ceiling gets up or something may go so
good never mentioned to the Flyway gets
kicked out of the town and put on the
train yeah it's like oh you ordered some
money pregnant like it didn't mean to
fullfil a bowl just the whole to the
bowl with the Pope I don't know the
Ferdinand story
I don't whether to me like educator so
that's not my style
I prefer if you don't know [__] I like
that but yeah I mean that seems like
it's going to be really heartbreaking
part where he has to go on to train for
the middle of the movie or they're like
yet to get him out of town they have to
become a fighting bolt and man I can't
tell you the amount of cage matches I've
been thrown into the amount of people
whose asses I have had to kick like a
very relatable film yeah this is vicious
all this burden Greg Ferdinand is what
they could have called yeah I think it
would have made like more sense it would
have made more sense yeah we look alike
too
I could have at least voiced the bull
back through a little cute animation
stuff with like the the bunny and howdy
you really like stuff like bellowing air
who watch the bunny they get invited
ones little cute oh my god get a sense
of humor Renee now we learn a laugh at a
dairy once in a while I can practice
like last therapy while we're watching
it ha is that your date laughing yeah
but the other characters look like it
looks this looks like it could be on par
with you know a lot of other great
Disney films and I'm wondering for the
human character is it's like a calling
after four I was a little girl
yeah so love interest the love interest
is buddy it could be that's the
situation with every girl that falls in
love with me beauty and a little girl
yes
don't don't go there
relatable I read the beauty in the be
smart how I'm the beauty and I keep
dating these Hagrid types you know yeah
totally I don't know what my problem is
Express okay
I just like beards of a woman some
people like that the preference hairy
armpits
you have hairy armpits I know I know now
we're gonna work
mmm I don't know what you showed up that
we will go one video without making it
awkward I promise
well thanks robbers requesting that b1g
red a14 seriously man I don't know why
my mom became memory does nothing to
have such a complicating YouTube Nick
Rene is not a real name her real name is
very complex shippin Stein no one wants
to call her that so she goes everything
my name's alaya yeah I understand I
understand and people when they hear my
name they go oh you know like - I really
interpret it but there's another like
uglier fatter actor out there
kids been so get a different name okay
for name hey subscribe to the real
rejects Renee follow her on YouTube hey
Renee follow her on Instagram hey her
neck follow her on Twitter you could
catch her videos you can get dick dad
promotion follow her on afterbuzz TV as
well and she's on this like react series
with Amber placer
she's all over the Internet why aren't
you all over her do it now